اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تغطيه العاجله
والمباشره لنزاع المسلحه في السودان
مستمره الصراع يدخل اسبوعه الثاني ولا
بوادر للتهدئه يوم تاسع اذا من الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع وصل
اتهامات متبادله بين قائدي الجيش والدعم
السريع بخرق الهدنه بينما ارقام تتزايد
للضحايا والمصابين وفي اخر احصائيات
مشاهدينا نشر مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه
يعرض فيه اعداد القتلى والمصابين في
اشتباكات السودان وتبيعاتها حيث رصد مقتل
412 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اخرين حتى يوم الجمعه الماضيه العاصمه
الخرطوم مشاهدين تصدرت المدن في اعداد
القتلى بمئه واثنين
تريها ولايه شمال كردفان بخمسه وتسعين
قتيلا وشمال دارفور بواحد 61 قتيلا بحسب
التقليل الذي اشار ايضا الى زياده عمليه
النزوح من جميع مناطق الخرطوم ومدينه
الابيض بشمال كردفان
بسبب استمرار الاشتباكات وكشفت تقي الامم
مشاهدينا عن اللجوء نحو 20 الف سوداني الى
تشاد وقال انهم يعانون الان من ظروف
انسانيه صعبه محذرا من ان الافتقار لمياه
الشرب قد يؤدي الى زياده خطر الاصابه
بالامراض بما في ذلك الكوليرا
[موسيقى]
على صعيد عمليه الاجلاء المستمره اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه بدء عمليه اجلاء
سريعه لمواطنينها ولطاقمها الدبلوماسي من
السودان بعد ان دخلت المعارك العنيفه
اسبوعها الثاني والفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الى ان العمليه ستشمل ايضا مواطنين
اوروبيين واخرين منحدرين من دول شريك
حليفه وانها حصلت على ضمانات من طرفي
الصراع في السودان لتامين عمليه الاجلاء
اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع
بارتكاب انتهاكات ضد بعثه دبلوماسيه ليله
امس وذكر الجيش السوداني في بيان ان عناصر
من الدعم السريع اعتدت على السفير
الماليزي والبعث القطري المتجهه الى
بورسودان كما تعرض موكب السفاره الفرنسيه
لاطلاق نار ما ادى الى عودتهم وتعطيل
عمليه الاجلاب في المقابل قالت قوه الدعم
السريع في بيان ان طائرات الجيش هي التي
استهدفت موكب السفاره الفرنسيه
وشددت الدعم السريع على التزامها بالهدنه
وتسهيل حركه الراعي الاجانب لمناطق
الاجلاء
في المقابل نفى المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع فارس النور نفا طرحه
انفسهم كبديل للجيش واكد استعداد الدعم
السريع للاندماج بالجيش بعد تطهيره من
عصابات سيطرت عليه وفق تعبيره
ان الجيش السوداني الان
مخترع
يعني احنا ما صالحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
نحن دايرين نطهر الجيش السوداني من
العصابه التي سيطرت عليه وبعد ذلك الجيش
السوداني هو الاساس لكي نكون جيش قومي نحن
سوف نندمج في الجيش السوداني لكي نكون جيش
رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بديلين للجيش
اكد المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم
السريع ان هدفهم الرئيسي انجاز انجاز
التحول الديمقراطي لدوله مدنيه
نحن دخلنا هذه المعركه هدفنا الرئيسي
والذي الان اذا المعركه حتجيب بسبب هذا
الهدف هو انه يتم تسليم السلطه للمدنيين
وانسحاب المكون العسكري من العمليه
السياسيه لايجاد التحول الديموطي لطلبوا
الطلبه السوداني دي مهمتنا وده دورنا وده
اللي حنمشي فيه وده اللي مضحي من
اجره تم اتهم المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات
الدعم السريعه ناصر بتنفيذ الاعتداءات على
الدبلوماسيه وتحميل مسؤوليتها للدعم
السريع
هنالك
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم من ضربوا
الرصاص على السيارات السفاره الامريكيه هم
اعتدوا على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
مشاهدينا الخرطوم ينضموا الينا مراسله
عربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم وكيف
تبدو تطورات الاوضاع في العاصمه الخرطوم
اهلا بك احمد وبكل صدى المشاهدين بدايه
التطورات الاوضاع اليوم التاسع تواصلت
الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم
وايضا بين الجيش والقوات الدعم السريع بعض
الاحياء في مدينه بحري الخرطوم كان هناك
تحليق للطيران الحربي بحسب شهود عيان
وبحسب ما راينا كذلك
اصوات ايضا لمبادات الطائرات
هذه اصوات مضادات الطائرات مرتبطه كذلك
باصوات لمدافع ثقيله وخفيفه كذلك خدمت
الانترنت قطع
شبكه واحده وتعمل يعني ليست بكفاءه عاليه
فهي متذبذبه تكون موجوده احيانا واحيانا
غير موجوده ايضا خدمه الاتصالات لبعض
الشبكات
قطعت العديد من ولايات السودان كذلك ايضا
هناك في التيار الكهربائي في مناطق مختلفه
من الخرطوم وهناك احياء ما زالت خدمه
الكهرباء لم تصل اليها حتى الان منذ بدايه
هذه
الازمه حتى اليوم التاسع على التوالي يضاف
اليها ايضا المياه التي ايضا تدخل الى
يومها التاسع
احياء مدينه بحري او استطيع ان اقول جل
مدينه بحري الان لا توجد بها ضياء فندق
اليوم منذ تجدد الاشتباكات وحتى اليوم هي
تسعه ايام الان حواليا كذلك بعض الاحياء
في مدينه ام درمان وبعض الاحيان في مدينه
الخرطوم كذلك هناك ايضا بدات حركه النزوح
من الخرطوم الى الولايات المجاوره لها
وبعض حالات النزوح ليست كثيره ايضا لكنها
موجوده في النزوح الى دوله مصر لبعض الاسر
السودانيه حالات النزوح هذه هي لمجموعه من
الاسر حتى للولايات ايضا معهم اطفال في
حرص منهم على البعد عن المناطق التي يقل
فيها الامن تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات فيها
اصوات الرصاص بالاضافه الى الرعب الموجود
في الشوارع كذلك حينما تلتقي بهذه القوات
طيب سالم مدينه بحريه وامس اشتباكاتنا
عنيفه خاصه في منطقه شامبات كيف يبدو
الوضع فيها حاليا وما سبب تلك الاشتباكات
التي جرت يوم امس والتي ايضا راحه ضحيتها
عدد من
المواطنين ايضا العسكري بالتاكيد
نعم شهدت بالامس اشتباكا عنيفا مدينه بحري
ليس في شنبات واحده احمد ايضا في مناطق
اخرى من مدينه تحرير لكن في منطقه في
منطقه في حي الشمات في التقاطع
مدينه مدينه البراحه الطبيه في هذه
المنطقه شهدت اشتباكً عليكم بالقرب من
السوق المركزي كذلك احترق جزء من السوق
المركزي ومسجد السوق المركزي
وتضررت المباني السكنيه مجمع البشير
السكني ليس بشكل كبير لكن هناك ضرر
وصلت الى هذه المجمعات السكنيه ولقات
الرصاص وكذلك طلقات الدوشكا في هذه
المدينه السكنيه وهناك كان رعب رهيب عاشه
المواطنون في حي شنبات من هذه المعركه
التي كانت هناك هي قوات الدعم السريع
الجيش السوداني لكل تاكيد شارك فيها ايضا
الطيران الحربي للقوات السودانيه التي
قصفت هذه المنطقه التي كانت تتمركز فيها
قوات الدعم السريع والتي كانت تشترك مع
قوه تتبع للجيش السوداني ربما هذه يعني
جاءت متماشيه معه ما ذكره الجيش السوداني
بالامس المكان لديه تمشيط في بعض المناطق
او ما ذكرته حتى الوسائل المختلفه من ان
هناك تمشيط للجيش السوداني وبعد هذه
المعارك سالم التي اشرت اليها يعني ماذا
عن حضور الطرفين اي طرفين له الحضور
الاكبر الان في منطقه بحري بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
نعم هو
الاشكال احمد انه يصعب ان تقول ان هذه
المنطقه تتبع لهذه الجهه او لتلك لكن ما
هو على الارض ان هناك احياء تتحرك فيها
القوات الدعم السريع وهذا واضح بالنسبه
للمنطقه
المزاد مثلا وكذلك الشعبيه الشمال وجنوب
لزمن حي شمبال فكذلك حلت حمد هذه المناطق
تتحرك فيها القوات الدعم السريع بين الفين
والاخرى في الشوارع الشوارع خاليه تماما
من الماره منذ الامس او منذ اول امس يعني
الحركه تبدو غير موجوده على الافطار في
المحلات التجاريه مغلقه كذلك هذا الامر
اثار الرعب لدى المواطنين تحرك هذه القوات
الاخرى ومحاوله الجيش السوداني استهدافها
كذلك بين الفين والاخرى اما للطيران او
حتى بان تقترب منها قوه ايضا الرعب لدى
المواطنين في هذه المناطق لكن بشكل الوضع
يعني الان هناك هدوء دائما نسميه بالهدوء
الحذر والذي يجعل المواطنين يعني حذرين
حتى في الحركه الان الشوارع في مدينه بحري
فيها الذين يتحركون من يبحثون على الماء
فقط لانه مشكله المياه بالفعل باتت واحده
من الامور التي هي لوحدها كافيه للنزوح من
هذه المنطقه استهداف الطيران الذي اشرت
اليه لهذه القوات قوات الدعم السريع يعني
هل يتم في المناطق المفتوحه فقط ام حتى في
المناطق السكنيه ايضا
عمل الجيش السوداني كان قد تحدث عن هذا
الامر بانه يستهدف الدعم السريع بدقه وانه
حريص على المدنيين وانه يحترم كذلك
القوانين الدوليه في مساله الاشتباكات هذا
من مصادر عسكريه كثيره اكدوا هذا المعنى
وانهم لم يستهدفوا المدنيين لا بالطيران
ولا بغيره وانهم سيكونون حريصين على حياه
المدنيين كذلك في هذه الاشتباكات وفي هذه
الحرب الدائره
بالمقابل
يصعب جدا
القول بان هذا الامر يمكن ان يمضي بسهوله
وبهذه الطريقه هذا على ارض الواقع لان
ايضا قوات الدعم السريع بين الفين والاخرى
تدخل الى الاحياء خاصه وشاهدها شهود عيان
كثر نقلوا لنا هذا الامر بان هذه حينما
تبدا حركه الطيران مباشره تدخل هذه
السيارات الى الاحياء ينزل منها الجنود
ويمشون راجلين متفرقين ربما خوف من
[موسيقى]
هي تبدو افضل حاله في الاحياء البعيده عن
مناطق الاشتباك وهنا نقصد الاحياء البعيده
من محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون الاحياء
البعيده كذلك من المهندسين وحتى البعيده
من حي الصالحه اقصى جنوب غرب ام درمان هذه
المناطق الثلاثيه التي تتجدد فيها
الاشتباكات وفيها انقطاع للمياه انقطاع
ايضا للتيارات الكهربائي ايضا فيها ذعر
هناك محل تجاريه مغلقه تبدو شوارعها خاليه
تشبه ما يدور في احياء بحري السكنيه ايضا
لكن ما هو بعيد قليلا من هذه المناطق ربما
فيه حركه
حركه للمواطنين شبه طبيعيه بعض المحلات
التجاريه تعمل كذلك سوى بعض الازمات التي
هي الوقود مثلا
الماده الاخرى في الامداد الغذائي نفسه
قليلا ايضا بدت في تلك المناطق تحسن قليل
في اليومين الماضيين امس
بدا تحسن قليل في مساله الامداد الغذائي
والمساله الاسعار كذلك من هنا شكاوى ايضا
من المواطنين من ارتفاع جنون الاسعار
والسلع بشكل غريب هذه كلها ربما تجعل ايضا
الوضع بشكل عام غير متزن في كل المناطق
لكن ربما هي هذه الاحياء هي الاكثر امنا
في ولايه الخرطوم وفيما يتعلق ايضا
بالمستشفيات سالم يعني ما اخر ما توفى لك
معلومات حول اوضاع فيها
الاوضاع في المستشفيات ظل الكوادر الطبيه
يرسلون لنا المناشده بين الفين والاخرى
ومنذ اندلاع هذه الازمه وحتى الان شكاوى
من كوادر الطبيه من عدم وصول كوادر الطبيه
للمستشفيات شكاوى ايضا من انقطاع
الامدادات المتعلقه
اللوجستيه في المستشفيات المعينه على
العمل في الطوارئ وفي الاصابات لانهم
يتلقون حالات من الاصابات والطوارئ تاتيهم
اتباع يريدون ان يتعاملوا معهم قله هذه
الامدادات وقله الكوادر الطبيه كذلك في
المستشفيات يجعل المستشفيات تبدو في حاله
اسوا يضاف الى ذلك عدم القدره على الحركه
في الشوارع نفسها في نقل المصابين من مكان
الاصابه الى المستشفى كل هذه الامور من
العمل في المستشفيات
المستشفيات الان اكبر نداء تناديه هي
تنادي بان يكون هنالك طرق امنه توفر لهذه
المستشفيات من اجل الوصول الكوادر الطبيه
الى هذه المستشفيات ومباشره اعمالها ومن
اجل الوصول كذلك الدعم اللوجسكي لهذه
المستشفيات
لتباشر عملها بشكل صحيح هل بعض هذه
المستشفيات تقع تحت سيطره طرف معين يعني
كما بعض الاباء تفيد ان مستشفى شرق النيل
وهو من المستشفيات الكبيره في العاصمه
الخرطوم ايضا يقع فقط تحت سيطره قوات
الدعم السريعه التي تعالج فيها منسوبيها
المصابين
نعم بالفعل هو هذا يضاف الى ذلك انه اغلب
المستشفيات يعني غالبا المستشفيات في
مدينه بحري وفي مدينه الخرطوم اغلقت تماما
بحكم الامر الواقع لانه لا يستطيع احد
الوصول اليها ولا يصلها
تستطيع ان تباشر اعمالها فاولقت العديد من
المستشفيات بالفعل
اغلقت تماما من استقبال الحالات لانها لا
تستطيع ان تجابه كل هذه التحديات وذكر لنا
الاداريين في هذه المستشفيات التي اغلقت
بانهم يعانون من امور كثيره جدا منها
الكوادر الطبيه منها القطاع المياه كذلك
في المستشفيات التي تسعه ايام تواليا عدم
القدره على توفير هذه المياه عدم القدره
على توفير قواعد الطبيه تعمل عدم القدره
على جلب المزيد من الامداد لمواصله العمل
كل هذا جعل العديد من مستشفيات تخرج خارج
الخدمه بالفعل اصبحت المستشفيات التي تعمل
قليله جدا وتعمل بكفاءه متدنيه جدا بحكم
هذه العوامل الكثيره جدا الطيفي متعلق
بطرق السفر سالم سواء الى بورسودان او الى
مدني او حتى حركات النزوح المتوجهه كما
اشرت في بدايه حديثك الى مصر هل تبدو طرق
امنه هل هناك من عقبات يواجهها المسافرون
بالنسبه لحالات النزول النزوح بدا منذ
اليوم الاول لكنه في اليومين الماضيين بدا
اكثر حتى نتحدث عن حركه النجوم وهي يعني
ادنى درجات النزوح وهي الخروج من مناطق
النزاع الى مناطق ابعد قليلا واكثر امنا
في احياء بعيده من المناطق التي تحدث فيها
النزاع هذه حركه النزوح بدات منذ اليوم
الاول ازدادت وترتها في اليومين الماضيين
الان حركه النزوح في نطاق اوسعي لانها
انتقل الى ولايات مختلفه من الولايات
المحيطه الولايات الخرطوم وربما الابعد
منها كذلك هناك حركه نزوح الى جمهوريه مصر
العربيه كذلك كل هذه حركات نزوح بدات
بالفعل بالخروج من الاسر من هذه المناطق
ابتعادا عن الحرب وابتعاد عن هذه الازمه
الامنيه حقيقه التي يعاني منها المواطن
تضاف اليها بق
يه بالنسبه للطرق هناك شكاوى من بعض
المواطنين لان هناك طرق اعترضتهم فيها
قوات الدعم السريع وهناك طرق اعتراضهم
فيها ايضا نهب او ما يسمى بقطاع الطرق
ايضا ظهروا كذلك موضوع النهب والسلب كل
هذه الامور تدفع الى تساؤلات كبيره جدا
وظل مغردون سودانيون في تويتر فيسبوك
يتساءلون عن دور الشرطه السودانيه في
حمايه الممتلكات وفي حمايه المواطنين وفي
انتشار هذه الشرطه لانه بالفعل في المناطق
التي تشهد الاشتباكات وتشهد هذه الاعمال
هناك غياب لدور الشرطه السودانيه وهذا
مستغرب حقيقه طيب معك مؤقتا بهذا القدر
سالم ونعود اليك في سياق هذه التغطيه شكرا
لك من الخرطوم كنت العربيه سالم الهاشمي
مشاهدينا نذكر بالاخبار العجله تبدو الان
وتظهر على شاشه العربيه الان الخارجيه
المصريه قبل قليل قاده العربيه ان ملف
اعاده الجنود المصريين من السودان اغلق
بشكل كامل ومصادر العربيه ايضا تتحدث عن
ان مصر ستمنح تاشيره الدخول للرعايه
الاجانب القادمين من السودان ومصالح
العربيه ايضا القاهره انهت التنسيق مع
الجيش السوداني الاجلاء رعاياها عبر
طائرات مصريه
مشاهدينا اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
اصابه احد اعضاء السفاره في الخرطوم بطلق
ناري واكدت ان هذا الحادث يؤكد مره اخرى
على ضروره توخي اقصى درجات الحذر حفاظا
على سلامه المواطنين والدبلوماسيين ودعت
الخارجيه المصريه المواطنين المصريين
الموجودين خارج الخرطوم الى التوجه الى
مدينتي حلفا وبورسودان تمهيدا لاجلاهم
قال السفير الروسي في السودان اندريه تشير
نوفال ان الدبلوماسيين الروس في السودان
يدرسون جميع الطرق الممكنه لاجلاء
المواطنين وتنفيذ عمليه اجلاء جويه في حال
تحسنت الاوضاع في المطار واشار الى ان
مغادره الرعايه الروس الى بورسودان ممكنه
من الناحيه النظريه لكنها مرتبطه بصعوبات
لوجسيه تتعلق بالنقل والامن كما اشار
السفير الروسي لان طرفي الصراع في السودان
مستعدان للمساعده في اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب لكن هناك صعوبات موضوعيه تحول دون
تحقيق ذلك
في السياق ذاته مشاهدين اقامه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بعمليه اجلاء نوعيه
لرعاياها من مقر السفاره الامريكيه في
ضاحيه سوبا جنوب الخرطوم وذلك بمشاركه ست
طائرات امريكيه هبطت في مبنى السفاره
وكانت قياده الدعم السريع السودانيه اصدرت
بيانا اوضحت فيه ان قواتها نسقت مع القوات
الامريكيه المكونه من ست طائرات بغرض
اجلال الدبلوماسيين واسرهم وان قوات الدعم
السريع قامت بالاشراف على الترتيبات
اللازمه التي سبقت عمليه الاجلاء
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اكد عمليه
الاجلاء التي قال ان الجيش الامريكي نفذها
باوامر منه واشار بايدن الى ان الجيش نجح
في اجلاء الامريكيين الى بر الامان متوجها
بالشكل للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وجيبوتي
واثيوبيا حيث وصف بايدن دور هذا هذه الدول
بالحاسمه في نجاح عمليه الاجلاء ودعا
الرئيس الامريكي الاطراف المتحاربه لتنفيذ
وقف فوري وغير مشروط لاطلاق النار والسماح
بوصول المساعده الانسانيه دون عوائق
واحترام اراده شعب السودان
من جهته قال وزير خارج الامريكي ان بلاده
علقت بصفه مؤقته العمليات في سفارتها
بالخرطوم بسبب تزايد المخاطر الامنيه
واجلت جميع الموظفين الامريكيين وعائلاتهم
بامان واضاف بلينك ان اداره الامريكيه
ستواصل مساعده الامريكيين في السودان في
التخطيط لسلامتهم مكررا الدعوه لطرفي
الصراع بتمليد هدنه العيد وتوسيع نطاقها
على نحو عاجل من اجل وقف دائم للاعمال
القتاليه
معسكر
رسميا هو القاعده العسكريه الدائمه
والوحيده التي تديرها القوات الامريكيه في
افريقيا
جغرافيا هي اقرب قاعده امريكيه في المنطقه
للاحداث في السودان وهي تقع في دوله
جيبوتي
القاعده تضم وحدات من القوات الخاصه
والبحريه والطيران ويصل عدد القوات فيها
الى 4000 جندي في الاوقات العاديه تستغل
لحمايه الملاحه البحريه في باب المندب وفي
استهداف الجماعات الارهابيه في القرن
الافريقي اضافه الى تدريب الجنود التابعين
لدول افريقيه مختلفه
معسكر لمونيي يحتوي على مطار عسكري قد
يكون هو المحور الاساسي في اي عمليه اخلاء
محتمله للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
انس النماسي العربيه
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينضموا الينا الباحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسه السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
صلاح خليل اهلا بك
على الابعات الدبلوماسيه في الايام تسعه
الماضيه تكررت بشكل كبير في السودان
نتحدث عن البعثه الامريكيه في البدايه بعد
ذلك تعرضت اليوم البعثه الفرنسيه وايضا
احد اعضاء السفاره المصريه هل هي في
تقديرك اعتداءات
متعمده وممنهجه
لا اعتقد ذلك انها ممانجه ولكن تشير بوضوح
ان
الرعايه هو تقييم قامت به الدول
او السفارات الاجنبيه في الخرطوم بعد دخول
الازمه اسبوع الثاني ولا زال تجدد
الاشتباكات في العديد من المناطق وايضا هي
اشاره ايضا واضحه بان الوضع على مستوى
الخرطوم كعاصمه لم يكن عاملا خاصه في ظل
غياب الشرطه
وايضا تراجع ودورها في العديد من المناطق
وايضا بسبب
الحجوم الذي
تقوم به القوات الدعم السليم ضد العديد من
الممتلكات والمنشات خاصه في النقطه دي
دعني اشير الى بعض السلبيات والتجاوزات
التي قامت بها قوات الدعم السريع
الهدن التي سبقت هذه
الازمه او بعد مناشدات دوليه واقليميه
كانت لابد ان ان نشير الى مميزات هذه
الهدنه بالنسبه للطرفين وهو ده السبب الذي
جعل
قوات الدعم ان تقوم ببعض هذه التجاوزات
عندما نتحدث ان الهدن ففي القالب بالنسبه
للمؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه سوف تستخدم
استراتيجيه النفس الطويل عدم
انزلاق عديد من الضحايا السودانيين
فبالتالي تتبع عمليه ضبط النفس اما
بالنسبه للاستراتيجيه للدعم السريع فهي
دائما تعتمد او تتميز القتال في الفضاءات
والمساحات المتسعه والكبيره وايضا هو هذا
السبب جعلها ان تكون في حاله سكون فربما
تتخوف من عمليه او مصير كلما
هنالك هدنه ثم تلحقها حودا اخرى فبالتالي
تسبب لها الجذور كبير من فقد الايتاد
وايضا والمؤن الغذائيه وهذا هو ما حدث
راينا كميه من اخوات الدعم السريع لجات
لاسلوب السطو للمحلات التجاريه وايضا
انتشرت فيديوهات كثيره وربما
المستشاره السياسي لقائد الدعم السميتي
كان معنا في نشاط سابقه وقال انما ينسب
اليه من تجاوزات تقف وراه القوات المسلحه
السودانيه الذي التي يرتدي بعض منسوبيها
زي الدعم السريع ويقوبنا بهذه الاعتداءات
يعني المعلومه وتقديرك لما ما ذكرها
لا لا اعتقد ما يقوله مستشار الدعم الصريح
صحيح لان راينا السودانيين هم الذين
المدنيين هم الذين صورون القوات الدعم
السرير انا نتكلم بصراحه عندما نتحدث ان
المهنيه في التغطيه يجب ان تكون كما هي
راينا تجاوزات ثوراتها تم تصويرها من خلال
السوداني من شرفات منازلهم انه ماذا فعلت
قوات الدعم السريع في في مصانع سيجا وفي
شركه سيجا والى اخره ومحلات تجاريه سوبر
ماركت الحاوي في نمره ثلاثه الى اخر لانه
عمليه
دعنا اشيل النقطه دي لماذا هي لجوات قوات
الدعم لذلك لانه عمليه حرب الشوارد تحتاج
ايضا الى الى نفس القوات الدعم السريع
ايضا حددت فتره زمنيه ربما عندما دخلت في
هذا الصراع هددت فتره زمنيه بان هذه
الفتره الزمنيه هي كانت كفيله
ان تصل الى مرادها ولكن الواقع اقصى ذلك
فبالتالي هي فقدت جزء كبير من انعتادها
فقدت جزء كبير من المؤن التي كانت تخزنها
او تضعها في مخازن حتى تستفيد منها اطوال
هذه الفتره فبالتالي المحلات التجاريه
مغلقه فبالتالي عمليه الشراء والبي مغلقه
فبالتالي لجات اقوات الدعم السرير لذلك
عندما يتحدث مستشار الدعم السريع ان هنالك
تجاوزات قامت بها المؤسسه عسكريه لا تقل
ذلك لان عندما صور السودانيين كانوا
الشخصيات بالزي العسكري للقوات الدعم
السريع وايضا كانوا يرعبون المواطنين
فبالتالي ينزلون من مدرات ومن تاشرات اذا
كان الاسلاميين لديهم هذه القوه بما كانوا
سقطا ثانيا عندما
المدرعات
صلاحيه موجوده لدى الجيش والامر لا يحتاج
سوى الى
ارتداء ملابس الدعم السريع يعني هذه بحسب
روايه المستشار السياسي لحمايه طبعا يعني
اين مساله تزييف
صعبا بالنسبه لقوات الجيش هذا ما يقوله
بالتاكيد هو لا لا لا لا اعتقد كان هنالك
اذا كان هنالك
لانه
المؤتمر الوطني او الاسلاميين يشاركون في
هذه الازمه لكانت الموضوع
اخر وكان للراي السوداني منعطف اخر دائنا
احنا راينا
طرفي الصراع ومن يتحدثون نيابه عنهم او ما
يمثلونهم يتحدثون عن عمليه تسليم السلطه
للمدنيين والديمقراطيه هل الديمقراطيه
تتطبق في الجو او في البحر الديمقراطيه
تتطبق الى اين اذا كان ارادوا تطبيق
الديمقراطيه وتسليم السلطه للمدنيين يجب
ان اولنا الحفاظ على الدوله اذا لم تكن
هنالك دوله فكيف تكون هنالك ديمقراطيه هذا
كلام او اذا كانت الديمقراطيه لديها معنى
اخر تطبق في اماكن اخرى اذا كان ولكن اذا
ما رايناه انه هنالك وهدات تاثير
استراتيجيه في السوشيال ميديا وعلى مستوى
الاعلام من طرفي الصراع كلاهما يديدان
اداره الملف ويخفا لرؤيته
ما يتحدث به كثير الذين سواء كان ينتمون
الى المؤسسه العسكريه او ينتمون الى الدعم
السريع كانهم يتحدثون في واقع بعيد كل
البعد ان الواقع الذي نشاهده الان العالم
اصبح يعني يعني الثوره المعلومات من
العالم خليه عندما هنالك تجاوزات حصلت من
الدعم السريع راينا في السجون يعني دعنا
نقول هذا ما قاموا به الذين
تم اطلاقهم سواء كان من سجن او من سجن
الحج جنوبا غربيه ام درمان قالوا نحن قوات
الدعم السريعين التي اطلقت صلاه فبالتالي
ولكنهم قالوا ان الدعم اخرجهم من السجون
لانهم موجودون في هذه السجون بلا ماء ولا
طعام
دعنا نتكلم عندما تتجاوز سلطاتك التي
مخوله لك دعنا نتكلم عن ماذا يكون رايي
العام السوداني الراي العام السوداني
عندما يتم اطلاق سته الف سجنا في سجن سوبا
فبالتالي يرجعون لممارسه عمليه ارتكاب
جرائم ضد الشعب السوداني احنا نتكلم عن
قضيه راي عام سوداني فبالتالي يجب ان نرى
ذلك ما قامت به قوات الدعم السريعيه
تجاوزت فيه الرايه الامر السوداني الان
يعني تلك التجاوزات اصبح يعني في خانه
الصفر يعني لماذا يعني ما هو الغرض من
الاطلاق الدعم السريع لهؤلاء المساجين من
السجون ما هو الهدف
النزلاء محكوم عليهم في الاديت من القضايا
فعندما تقوم بتحرير سجناء ارتكبوا الاديد
من الجرائم فبالتالي وتم زج بهم في السجون
وتقوم باطلاقهم فبالتالي ربما يقومون
بعمليه انتقاميه في ظل في حاله ظل الظروف
التي يمر بها في السودان في الوقت الراهين
دعنا ايضا نشير الى نقطه مهمه جدا يعني
الثراء بين طرفي
المعادله في السودان انصح التعبير كان
عليهما
استنطاق للضغوطات التي مورست لهم ولكن
ايضا يستميتان في عمليه اقصاء اي طرف
للطرف الاخر وايضا يعملان من غير مراعاه
للشعب السوداني دعنا دعنا لو انتهت الحرب
يعني يعني لطرف لصالح طرف من الاطراف
اعتقد انه شاب سوداني سوف يقبل بواحد منهم
لا اعتقد ذلك لان هي عمليه بالنسبه
للسياره السوداني عمليه الجرائم التي
ارتكبت لا يمكن ان تغفر لاي شخص من
الشخصيات التي هي هي داخل المعادله من
طرفيه الصراع لا يمكن ان تكون هذه
الحرب التي ادت الى مزيد من الدماغ ان
تكون تعدي من غير انه
السوداني رايا في ذلك هذه هي المعادله
المعادله يجب انه ان يكفها زي الطرفيه
المعادله من الدخول في حرب ربما يعني تقود
الى الى الى الى
تقسيم السودان الى دويلات يعني فبالتالي
يتحدثون انا عندما ارى يعني استمع العديد
من القوه السياسيه وعلى طرفين الصراع
يتحدثون عن الديمقراطيه وان المدنيه اين
المدنيه واين الديمقراطيه لو كان لديهم
ديمقراطيه اخرى يطالبون بها الديمقراطيه
تطبق في الاوطان لانها الديمقراطيه نظام
سياسي
ما اشار عليه البرهان وحمدت في الايام
الماضيه البرهان اكد مرارا انه لا خلافات
لديه مع الد عم السريع وان خلافته هي مع
الدجالو كذلك قد الدعم يتحدث ان لا خلافات
لهم مع الجيش وانما خلافهم مع قاده الجيش
وتحديدا البرهان هل يشيل ذلك بان الازمه
في السودان هي الان او بين الطرفين هي
بعيده كل البعد عن نطاقها القومي وانها
دعنا نقول في الاساسيه معركه تصفيه حسابات
شخصيه بين هذه الاطراف
[موسيقى]
في الوطن الراهن وايضا يعني هم تسببات
بجزء كبير جدا دعنا نسميه انا يعني نسبه
المياه في المئه من هذه الازمه تسببت
الاطراف الثلاثه القوه السياسيه وطرفي
المعادله في القوه السياسيه العسكريه هم
تسببها في ذلك لان ارتضياها بدخول الايجاد
الافريقي وايضا
الامم المتحده هم هؤلاء هذه الازمه حاليا
ايضا نفس الطريقه تطالب القوه السياسيه
بضغوطات دوليه وساطه من دول الجوار ووساط
والى اخره هذه ايضا تعدي يؤكل ان تكون
الازمه الداخليه
تطالب بساطات او مبادرات خارجيه من اجلها
يؤكل ان ذلك نحن في القرن 21 اي دوله يكون
لديها وساطه او مبادره تحمل اجندتها معها
وبالتالي الازمه سوف تستمر طيب من مصلحه
من تستمر هذه الازمه هو السياسيه دعنا
نتكلم القوه السياسيه المؤسسه العسكريه
الدعم السريع كلاهما كان ياكلان من نفس
المائده المؤتمر الوطني اذا اذا المشكله
المشكله ليست كانت مشكله الاسلاميين
وكانوا يتغاصبون مع الاسلاميين السلطه حتى
الاحزاب التقليديه فيها وكانوا يعني
يتناوبون في المناصب الوزاريه فالتالي
الازمه اذا ازمه بليه بنيه الدوله
السودانيه
يعني انتصار احد الطرفين في هذه الحرب هل
يعني فضل رؤيته التي كان يتبناها قبل هذه
المواجهات نتحدث عن ان التوسيع قاعده
المشاركه في العمليه السياسيه كانت هي من
ضمن مطالب الجيش وان المضيف للاتفاق
الايطالي كانت هي المطلب الاساسي لقوات
الدعم السريع اما ان الطرف المنتصر في
تقديرك ايضا قد يتبنى رؤيه جديده كليا
مستفيدا من موقعه الجديد بعد هذا الانتصار
لا اعتقد انه اي طرف اذا اقصى الطرف
الثاني ان يفرز سيطرته لانه اعتقد انه
الشعب السوداني ان يكون لديه كلمته وربما
ايضا يتم يعني يعني ارى كثير تناقشت مع
كثير من النقب السياسيه والمهتمين بشان
السودان السودانيين يعني كانوا يطالبون
بمحاسبه كل من ارتكبوا جرم في حق الشعب
السوداني فبالتالي لا يمكن يعني حتى لو تم
اقصاء طرف للطرف الاخر سوف يكون الطرف
الاخر بعيد كل البعد من المشهد السياسي
لان لان سوف يتحمل جزء كبير يعني يعني
يتحمل جزء كبير جدا من الازمه الحاليه
فبالتالي في القالب هيكون خارج المعادله
وايضا ربما يقدم الى محاكمه يعني فبالتالي
الشارع السوداني ايضا صامت ولكن لديه
لديه يعني رؤى ولديه استراتيجيه يتحدث
انها ويناقش انها بس بعيدا عن وسائل
الاعلام لذلك ربما لانه راينا هنالك يعني
حرب بيانات وكلام وراينا تصريحات لا تمت
بالصله للازمه الداخليه والقاتل والمقتول
الله اكبر فبالتالي لا نحن في ازمه حقيقيه
نحن نحن في ازمه تتلخص في فشل مشروع
الدوله السودانيه الوطنيه منذ الاستقلال
شكرا في ازمه تتحمل فيها كل المؤسسات
الدوله في السودان والقوه السياسيه في
كيفيه فشلها في عمليه بناء مشروع الدوله
السودانيه مشروع الدوله السودانيه الذي
يسيء للجميع نحن امام معضلها حقيقيه نحن
امام
ربما متجذره معقده
نقطه مهمه جدا عندما تم الاتفاق الاطاري
عندما تم الاتفاق الايطالي الاليه
الثلاثيه وكل الذين فاعلين في الازمه
السودانيه يعني لم يكون على درايه اعتذر
منك
الاجتماعيه
في مساحات اخرى شكرا لك من القاهره كنت
معنا الباحث في مركز الاهرام الدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه صلاح خليل تحياتي
عمليه لجلال الامريكيه مشاهدينا سبقتها
عمليه اجلاء سعوديه حيث قالت وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه ان مواطنين المملكه
الذين تم اجلائهم يا السودان وصلوا الى
البلاد اضافه الى عدد من رعايه الدول
الاخرى وبينت الوزاره في بيان ان القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه اجلت بل اجلت
واحدا 91 سعوديا ونحو 66 شخصا من عشر دول
اخرى عربيه واجنبيه واكدت الخارجيه ان
المملكه عملت على توفير كامل احتياجات
الاساسيه للرعايه الاجانب تمهيدا لتسهيل
مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
من جانبه قال نائب وزير الخارجي السعودي
وليد الخريجي ان معظم السعوديين الذين
طلبوا الاجلاء من السودان تم اجلائهم
وخلال استقباله السعوديين والرعايه
الاجانب العائدين من السودان الى جده اوضح
نائب وزير الخارجي السعودي ان هناك تكادفا
بين كافه الاجهزه لتنفيذ عمليه الاجلاء
مؤكدا ان وزاره الدفاع السعوديه لعبت دورا
كبيرا في تنفيذها واضاف ان لدى وزاره
الخارجيه توجيهات للعمل على راحه
السعوديين في الخارج
نتواجد على متن سفينه جلاله الملك ابها
وهي اخر سفن الخاصه الاول التي خصصت
لعمليات الاجلاء من السودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده على متنها 37 شخص
جنسيات متعدده بمقدمتها الجنسيه
الاماراتيه والقطريه وكذلك الجنسيه
البنغلاديشيه وغيرها من الجنسيات العربيه
وغير العربيه نتحدث عن 37 شخص وهي الدفعه
الاخيره من 158 شخص تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
برا الى بورت سودان ومن ثم بحرا الى مدينه
جده وتحديدا في قاعده الملكه فيصل البحريه
هنا في جده نتحدث عن عمليات جلاء تمت
بعمليات بكل يسر وسهوله من خلال تنسيق
عالي بين قطاعات حكوميه عده وبين السفاره
السعوديه وقوات البحريه السعوديه وكذلك
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه نتحدث عن واحد
وتسعين السعودي من ضمن المائه 158 شخص تم
اجلاهم اكثر من 11 جنسيه في اعمار مختلفه
مخصصه القوات البحريه خمسه سفن اربعه منها
هي خاصه بعمليات الاجلاء والخامسه كانت هي
خاصه بعمليات التموين جميعها وصلت منذ
ساعات مبكره وهذه هي السفينه الاخيره وهي
السفينه جلاله الملك
ابها وهي السفير الاخيره الخاصه بعمليه
النقل
وجلاء الرعايه نتحدث 158 شخص وصلوا جميعهم
الى مدينه جده وتحديدا في قاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه ونتواجد الان على متن السفينه
الاخيره الخاصه بعمليات الاجلاء نتحدث انه
وصلت تباعا بينهما ما يقارب الخمسه
واربعين دقيقه عمليه نقل تمت وفق تنظيم
ووفق تنسيقات عاليه بين الحكومه السعوديه
وعدد من الجهات هنالك في الخرطوم للتاكد
من وصول وسلامه كافه الرعايه من السعوديين
وغير السعوديين
عمليه تنظيم الاجلاء من الخرطوم كانت تسير
بشكل ممتاز رغم ان الرحله كانت مخيفه بعض
الشيء كنا خائفين جدا مما كان يجري هناك
بسبب المعارك لكن السفاره السعوديه اتت
الينا الى منازلنا لانقاذنا وذهبنا في
موكب الى بورت سودان ثم الى هنا بواسطه
السفن السعوديه لم تكن لدينا خطه للاجلاء
كنا نترقب فقط لكن السفاره السعوديه هي
التي ساعدتنا على المغادره كنت على متن
الخطوط السعوديه او من الناس اللي كنا
ركاب الطياره والحمد لله طلعنا بسلام
وطيبين وبخير وتم اجلائنا اول شيء وصلنا
للسفاره السعوديه ثم خرجنا من السفاره
السعوديه على اجراء
كان سلس وسهل الحمد لله ونشكر خدمه
الحرمين الشريفين وولي عهده الامين ووزير
الخارجيه وكل القائمين على هذا الاجلاء
الناجح
نعيد بالتفكير مشاهدينا بالتصريحات التي
ادلى بها رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان للعربيه
والتي اكد فيها ان كل مطاره السودان تحت
السياده الجيش السوداني باستثناء مطار
الخرطوم ونيالا واتهم البرهان قوات الدعم
السريع بتفتيش المنازل ومصادره الاموال
والاعتداء على الابعاثات الدبلوماسيه
مشيرا الى ان هذه القوات تنتشر في الاحياء
السكنيه والمجمعات الخدميه كل المطارات
تحت سيطر الجيش مع مطار الخرطوم في
اشكاليه ومطار نياله في اشكاليه بقيه
بطارات السودان كلها تحت سيطره الدوله
طبعا رعايه الدول اصابهم الحلا واصابهم
الخوف من الممارسات مجموعات الدعم السريعه
المنفرده داخل سكنيه وهي تفتش المنازل
وتصادر الاموال وتعتدي على انتشار
الدبلوماسيه دون اي مراعه لح
رمه المواطنين
الان هذه المجموعات منتشره داخل حياه
السكنيه داخل المجمعات الخدميه وتقوم
بافعاله الخلق والهلع وال
روح في الجانب الاخر كشف محمد حمدان نقلو
قائد قوات الدعم السريع في تصريحات للعربي
انه موجود في الخرطوم برفقه مقاتليه حيث
يحرص على توجيهم في المعارك وتتبع
التطورات الاشتباكات
انا متواجد داخل الخرطوم
موجود
الكل يفجر عميق انا موجود في كل
لكن هو موجود
في موضوع ثاني
وجود الجنرلين المتقاتلين في السودان يثير
تساؤلات كثيره رغم الانباء الوارده من
الجانبين فلا دليل قاطعا على مكان البرهان
ولا تاكيد مطلقا لمكان حميدتي رفيقا دربي
بالامس وعدوها اليوم لم يظهر ميدانيا منذ
بدايه المعارك في ساحه القتال
المعلومات الصادره عن اعلام الطرفين بحسب
الشرق الاوسط تشير الى وجود القاده
العسكريين للقوتين في المقر الرئيسي
للقياده العامه للجيش وسط العاصمه اي في
المحيط ذاته قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد
انه يتولى مهامه ولن يبرح مكانه قائلا انه
يدافع عن السودان
انا موجود في هيئه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومضارحه ولن ابارحها هذه مهنتي وهذا شرفي
من اخرج الا محمولا من على نعش قبل ذلك
البرهان ظهر في اليوم الثاني من
الاشتباكات في مقطع فيديو لمده ثوان قليله
داخل غرفه الى جانبه قاده عسكريون اما
ظهوره الثاني فكان يوم العيد في خطاب مسجل
صوتا وصوره توجه فيه بالتهنئه للشعب
السوداني
الترجيحات تقول ان الغرفه قد تكون ملجا
مخصصا للعمليات السريه في احدى الوحدات
العسكريه التابعه للجيش في مقر القياده
العامه او اي منطقه عسكريه في العاصمه او
خارجها
اما قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو
فمنذ بدء العمليات العسكريه لم يظهر على
الاطلاق غير انه اكد في مقابله عبر الهاتف
مع العربيه انه يقود المعارك العسكريه مع
قواته على الارض بنفسه
مراقبون يرون ان قاده الدعم السريع
يتخوفون من سيطره قاده الجيش على اجهزه
الاتصالات وان ظهورهم او اتصالاتهم عبر
الشبكات تسهل تحديد اماكن وجودهم
فكيف ستنتهي قصه الزعيم ونائبه في بلد بدا
يتحول معماره الى عصف ماكول جراء دراوه
المعارك بلال البجداني العربيه
مشاهدينا معي في الاستوديو من الرياضه
الكاتب الصحفي السوداني محمد جميل احمد
اهلا بك سيد محمد معنا في هذه التغطيه
بدايه اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب التي تابعناه
اليوم وبالامس ايضا يعني هل يخدم هذه
الازمه بمعنى انه قد يمهد تفرغ هذه
الدبلوماسيه والسفارات للعب دور ايجابي في
هذه الازمه في السودان مع العكس يعني هو
دلاله ربما على اتجاه الاوضاع نحو مزيد من
التعقيد
يبدو انه ما ذكرته اخيرا يعني هو شكل من
الاشكال يعني اتجاه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
وخروجها من السودان شكلهم اشكال دخول
البلد في مصر اكبر يعني لكن بالاشاره الى
موضوع الولايات المتحده في رعايه امريكان
غير البيع حتى الان في السودان
مجموعه من
الامريكان الموجودين حتى الان في
السودان وبالتالي هذا ربما يؤشر الى انه
الولايات المتحده ربما يعني يكون لها راي
معين حيال ابقاء هؤلاء الناس هؤلاء
الرعايه في السودان بالاضافه انه يعني حتى
الان في وارد الدراسه هذا الوضع لكن بصوره
عامه خروج البعثات الدبلوماسيه ومؤشره الى
انه
باتجاه التعذيب بصوره اكثر يعني البعض
يعوي على دور كبير للولايات المتحده في
وقف الازمه وفي تحجيمها عطفا على النفوذ
الكبيره التي تتمتع به محليا ودوليا ايضا
لكن هل تبدو الولايات المتحده الان عاجزه
عن احداث فارق فيما يحدث الان او وقف هذه
هذا التصعيد المتبادل بين الطرفين يبدو ان
التعقيدات التي حصلت يا استاذ احمد
تعقيدات كبيره جدا جدا لانه الصراع يعني
هذا الصراع نفسه
اصلا لا يمكن ابدا ان يكون سببا لكي يتفجر
بهذه الطريقه يعني خلاف على مواعيد او
مواقيت الدمج بين الطرفين لا يمكن ابدا ان
يؤدي الى هذه الحاله من تفجير العنف
الخرطوم هذا غير مبرر ابدا يعني وبالتالي
الاشكاليه الاساسيه في فرقاء نفسهم يعني
الفرعون المختلفين او الغائدين المختلفين
يعني هؤلاء طوروا عنف باتجاه خطير جدا جدا
وبالتالي يعني اذا انت عقدت الامور بهذه
الطريقه سيكون من الصعب جدا على الاخرين
العون هذه اشكاليه كبيره لكن الولايات
المتحده بصوره عامه حتى الان سياساتها
وضغوطات الدبلوماسيه هي الان حتى الان
تحفز ان تكون عبر الاطراف او عبر الجواهر
الاقليمي نحن نعرف انه في رباعيه الرباعيه
التي كانت تهتم السودان اللي هي تكون
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
السعوديه والامارات بالتالي الولايات
المتحده حتى الان تفضل ان تلعب هذا الدور
من خلال وسطاء في الاقليم او دول الجوار
يعني حتى الان لم تتولى مباشره الضغوط
يعني
من جديد مشاهدينا في تصريحاتنا العربيه
قبل قليل
قوات الدعم السريع فارس النور طرحه انفسهم
كبديل للجيش واكد استعداد الدعم السريع
للاندماجي في الجيش بعد تطهيره من عصابات
سيطرت عليه وقت تعبيره
ان الجيش
السوداني وهنا في نقطه مهمه حتى
يعني احنا ما صارحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
حنا دايرين نطهر الجيش السوداني من
العصابه التي سيطرت عليه وبعد ذلك الجيش
السوداني هو الاساس لكي نكون جيش قومي نحن
سوف نندمج في الجيش السوداني لكي نكون جيش
رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بديش
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
فارس تنور اكد ان هدفهم الرئيسي انجازوا
التحول الديمقراطي لدوله مدنيه
نحن دخلنا هذه المعركه هدفنا الرئيسي
والذي الان اذا المعركه حتجيب بسبب هذا
الهدف هو انه يتم تسليم السلطه للمدنيين
وانسحاب المكون العسكري من العمليه
السياسيه لانجاز التحول الديموطي للطلبوا
الطلبه السوداني دي مهمتنا وده دورنا وده
اللي حنمشي فيه وهو ده اللي مضحي من اجره
كما اتهم المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات
الدعم السريع فارس النور عناصر مندسته
بتنفيذ الاعتداءات على الدبلوماسيه
وتحميل مسؤوليتها للدعم السريع
هنالك الان
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم انضربوا
الرصاص على
السفاره الامريكيه هم اعتدوا على
سفيره الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعود مره اخرى
في حديث فارس النور وهذا الخطاب الاعلامي
الذي يتبناها الدعم السريع حول حديثه
دائما عن ان الجيش السوداني جيش المختطف
ويسيطر عليه اسلاميون يتحدث عن ان القرار
في يد علي كارديو اسامه عبد الله وغير ذلك
يعني ما مدى دقه هذه المعلومه لو انها
تاتي فقط في سياق البروباجندا بين الطرفين
انا اعتقد انه من الاهميه بمكان التامل في
السياق الانقلاب الذي يحدثه البشير منذ
العام
1989 يعني هذا الجيش بالفعل تمت ادلجته
وتسيسه منذ عام الف
وبالتالي كان واضح لان هذا الجيش تم تجريف
كبير جدا في غيلاته الاولى والقيادات
المهنيه وقياداته الفنيه لذلك يمكن القول
ان الجيش بوصفه الحالي هو كهيكل جيش كذلك
وكذلك يعني كقوال وكمان
لكن اعتقد انه التجليف الذي تم على نظام
السياسي على مدى 30 سنه احدث
اعاقات كبيره في جهاز الدوله العام كلها
دوله عام يعني في الوزارات في الهيئات في
الجيش وما نعيشه الان حتى الدعوه شكلهم
اشكال
يعني تخطيط الجيش
لمواجهه التمر في الدارفور يعني تعمل سريع
اصلا تم تخطيطهم قبل الجيش وبالتالي واضح
جدا ان هذه الازمه هي اصلا ازمه تراكمت من
فعل تاسيس الجيش وتسييس الحياه العامه
وادليجتها عبر نظام اسلام السياسي تطبيقات
الاسلام السياسي بصوره يعني اساسيه تؤدي
الى يعني احداث انقسامات داخل المجتمع
وداخل الدوله هذه السرديه الاساسيه
والسرديه يعني المهم التي تكون في قاعده
التحليل لكن طبعا العسكريين ينفون هذه
التهم الموجه اليهم ويريدون على ذلك
بانحياز الجيش للثوره السودانيه وانه هو
الذي ازاح نظام البشير فكيف يكون اذن
مؤدلجا وتابعا لنظام البشير
العسكريين انفسهم
على مدى اربع سنوات كان يصرح انه الجيش
الجيش
الان اختلف الوضع بالتالي يعني هذه
الاداعات او هذه الكلمات التي يعني على
عاهينها لا يمكن ان تفسر الحقيقه الحقيقه
انه هذا جيت نفسه قبل اربع سنوات عبد
الفتاح برهان وغيرهم الجيش كانوا يقولون
ان الدعم السريع والجيش حاله واحده وهذا
مؤكد وموثق في اليوتيوب موثق في كل
التصريحات بالتالي من الواضح جدا انه هذا
الصراع صراع حول السلطه وان الشعب
السوداني الان هو الضحيه لهذا الصراع هذا
الصراع ليس الصراعا من اجل الديمقراطيه
وليست صراعا من اجل السعاده انتقلت
الامارات وانما هذا هو الصراء حقيقي في
السلطه
واختلف الطرفان على كيفيه اداره السلطه
السياسيه نعم اذا ساكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا
لكم من الرياض الكاتب الصحفي السوداني
محمد جيميل احمد شكر لك
ربنا يعوض
[موسيقى]
ايه ده
تغطيه للاحداث في السودان مستمره مشاهدينا
لكن نتوقف مع ابرز الاخبار على الساحه
الدوليه يحتاج نائب وزير الخارجيه صيني
لم يشير الى مبدا الصديد واحده لكنه ساوى
بين قضيه تايوان وقضيه شبه الجزيره
الكوريه في اشاره منه بل في اشاره منه الى
قضيه شبه الجزيره الكوريه وقضيه تايوان
تختلفان تماما في طبيعتهما
دعا وزير خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبيين
القوات البحريه للدول الاعضاء في التكتل
الى القيام بدوريات في مضيق تايوان وشدد
بوريل في مقال لصحيفه لوغار
على ضروره ان تكون اوروبا حاضره بشده في
قضيه تايوان التي اعتبرها مهمه على الصعيد
الاقتصادي والتجاري والتكنولوجي
قال مسؤولون محليون انما لا يقل عن خمسه
صواريخ روسيه اصابت مدينه خارجيه شرق
اوكرانيا والمناطق المحيطه بها حيث كتب
حاكم المنطقه على تطبيق تيليجرام كتب ان
صاروخا اصاب منزلا في احدى القرى جنوب
المدينه بينما تسبب صاروخ اخر في اندلاع
حريق كبير في المدينه نفسها والحق بعض
الاضرار في مباني المدنيه هذا وتطلق روسيا
منذ اشهر طائرات مسيره وصواريخ ضد مجموعه
متنوعه من الاهداف الاوكرانيه في محاوله
لتدمير البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
مشاهدينا نعود الى استكمال تغطيه احداث
السودان الزميله نادي الخماش تصحبكم على
راس الساعه متابعه طيبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات